it's my great pleasure to introduce aha
noah that's fantastic
noah fleming uh noah is a phd student
uh working with tony pitasi at the
university of toronto
and he works on proof complexity in
general
uh and he's going to talk about proof
complexity of
practical integer programming
so without further ado noah go ahead
yeah thanks for the
introduction vijay um so unfortunately
uh for those of you who have seen my
fellows talk this talk is going to be
pretty similar to it yes i'm going to be
talking about the proof complexity of
practical integer programming and this
is based on a very recent work
with uh goose and polyetso potassium
bear and
victorson okay so the outline of my talk
is as follows so first we're going to
talk about
using proof complexity for algorithm
analysis you're all probably familiar
with this
then i'll talk about
the proof complexity of integer
programming and here i'll focus on
cutting planes and branching cut and how
branching cut
can be formalized um using this
stabbing planes proof system they'll try
to motivate stabbing planes as like a
query view of cutting planes uh
so like how dpl is sort of a query
version of tree-like
resolution and then to switch things up
from the previous talk i'll show you
hopefully if i have time how to get
short proofs
of any unsatisfiable system of linear
equations
in cutting points using this framework
all right so algorithm analysis from
proofs
so the general idea is if you have a
class of algorithms
you can formalize it as a proof system
and this allows you to
hide the practical details of the
algorithm
and then lower bounds on the
proofs in this proof system imply
lower bounds on the runtime of that
class of algorithms
so you've all seen this for cdcl which
can be formalized as
as resolution uh one you might not be as
familiar with is the
uh is in integer programming so you can
formalize the vitalgomore cutting planes
method as the cutting planes proof
system
uh so we're going to be focusing more on
integer programming
so what's interesting programming so
here you're given
a system of linear inequalities
and you're asked to find some integer
solution to them
um and because they're linear
inequalities we can view them as a
polytope
and the problem becomes fine given a
polytope find an integer point in it
so classic way to solve this problem is
these vitalgomore cutting planes
so to define that i'll need the notion
of a cg cut
so a half space i'm going to say that a
half space is valid for a polytope
if every real solution in the polytrope
uh satisfies the half space so here this
guy in yellow
uh on the right is a valid half space so
given a valid half space
with um an integer where a is integer
but b can be any real number a cg cut
from this
half space um is obtained by like
taking the ceiling of the right hand
side so what does this do
well you can see it in the picture here
it shifts the valid half space
inwards so it cuts out some of the
non-integer points in the polytope but
it preserves
all of the integer points and this is
just because
a is integral okay
um and and this is uh
well actually i'll get to that over
there um yeah so so uh photogrammetry
cutting planes
uh it's just a method to heuristically
add cg cuts
to the polytube um and they this is done
until either an integer
solution is found or the empty polytope
is deduced
and if if we deduce the empty polytope
uh via the cg cuts
then this is a proof that there was no
immature
solution in the politic because all of
these cg cuts just
satisfy um our preserved integer points
um yeah so coccolard and tehran in the
80s
observed this and they formalized
cutting plants as a proof system
so here um you're given a polytube that
doesn't contain any integer solutions
and you're going to certify this fact
so a cutting plane's proof of this fact
this is going gonna be a slightly
different
definition than what paul gave gave but
uh it's equivalent
so cutting plane's proof of this fact is
a sequence of polytopes
beginning with the initial one that
you're given and ending with the
empty polytope such that each
subsequent polytope is derived from a
previous one
by introducing a new cg cut so here's a
little example
so we start with p1 our initial polytope
use a valid half space
here's the cg cut on it you get p2 valid
half space cg cut
so on so forth p4
and then finally p5 the empty poly tip
so this is a cutting plane's proof of
size five there's five polytopes in this
sequence and
the proof size is just the number of
polytopes in the sequence
this is polynomially equivalent to the
number of bits you need to write down
the proof
um yeah so improve complexity cutting
planes is quite a powerful
algebraic proof system and it's very
well studied
um it has short proofs as the pigeonhole
principle
and it can also simulate resolution um
and at the 90s exponential lower bounds
were proved on it by
putlock so in the right here i have a
little hierarchy
of some popular proof systems um so the
ones in green are those that we have
super polynomial lower bounds on
and the ones in yellow we don't yet
quick question noah do you have a short
description
of the lower bound that padlock proved
what is the class of formulas
uh it it's
uh that's these interpolant formulas
basically his method is you
can con it's this method of feasible
interpolation that was introduced by
crycek
you can turn cutting planes lower bounds
into monotone real circuits and they get
lower bounds that way
um so the formulas are are somewhat
uh yeah yeah they're likely coloring
formulas
um
yeah as albert said um
yeah okay so uh cutting planes is very
well studied
in proof complexity but it's not really
used
by itself in practical integer
programming solving
so modern integer programming algorithms
combine cutting planes with
a branch and bound procedure into what's
known as branch and cut
so again branching cut is going to solve
the integer programming problem
by doing the following two steps so
first
we branch we break our polytope up
into subpolytopes such that every
integer solution is contained
in one of these subpolytops p1 to pk so
here's an example here's two half spaces
and
and there we've broken polytube up into
two polytopes
and in practice uh this branching is
either done
uh in sort of a dpl style where we
branch out the integer valve all the
possible integer values
to a variable or we branch on like
the um hamming weight of a subset of
coordinates or something like that
um but all the the branching that's done
in practice can be simulated by the
following rule where we pick an
arbitrary half space and we branch on
whether the half space is true or its
integer negation is true that is whether
ax is greater than or equal to b or ax
is less than or equal to b minus one
and then the second step is we cut so we
refine these polytopes that we got by
additional cutting planes
and then oh yeah so here's a little
example there we go
and then we recurse on each of the
polytubes that we got
okay um and so in 2018
uh we introduced the stabbing points
proof system
as a way to formalize practical branch
and cut algorithms
as a proof system um and
you can kind of think about static
planes as an extension of dpl to reason
about
linear inequalities so i'll show you
that in a minute
so to define stabbing planes let's start
with dpl
so you all know this i'll go through it
really quick
so dpll of refutation is just a decision
tree refutation
so here's an unsatisfiable cnn formula
you pick a variable you branch on
whether it's true
or false let's suppose that's false
branch another variable
let's suppose it's false again and we
violate a clause so we're going to label
that leaf of the violated clause
and you keep going and eventually
yeah you label every leaf with a
violated clause
and this is a proof that the original
cnn formula didn't have
any integer solutions already uh yeah
any solutions
um okay so we're interested in
uh the integer programming world so we
want to rephrase dpl
in this language so first of all here
um i've just rewritten the previous cnn
formula the cnn formula
as an equivalent and equally satisfiable
system
of integer linear inequalities um
yeah just using the standard
transformation
notice that on the right hand side we
have a constraint for each variable
saying that that variable falls between
zero and one
and so dpl in this world oh yeah first
so these are linear inequalities so we
can view this as a polygon
which is nice so dpll in this world
corresponds to branching on whether
uh picking a variable and branching on
whether that variable is less than or
equal to zero or greater than or equal
to one
and because we have these boolean uh
constraints saying that each fails
between zero and one
this is the same as just restricting to
uh
whether that variable is equal to zero
or equal to one and
here in red you can see the action uh
that this
query does on the uh on the polytip
um so let's go down the left path where
we've restricted
to the left half space and now we're
just left this single point here
that's inter intersecting uh x1 is equal
to zero
and we'll query again we get the empty
polytope
um and we can repeat this process to
derive the empty polytope at every leaf
right and because each of these queries
branching on whether x1 is less than or
equal to zero or equal to one
observe that like any integer point
satisfies
one of these two so because we've
derived the empty polytope at each leaf
this is a refutation of the claim that
the system of inequalities had an
integer solution all right
so stabbing plans it's just the
straightforward generalization of
this to query integer linear
inequalities
so rather than branching a single
variable now we pick an arbitrary
integer linear inequality
um and we branch on whether it's
true whether ax is greater or equal to b
or
it's false ax is less than b minus one
and because a and b are integral any
integer solution is going to satisfy at
least one of these two
okay so here's the action on the
polytope we introduce these two half
spaces
we rule out the spacing between them to
slab in between them and we are cursed
on both sides
so let's go down the left path now we're
at this polytope
again we query uh some half space
um and we keep going until we derive the
empty polytope now let's go back up and
do the right side
so now we're at this polytope we keep
going
we direct the empty polytope with all
the leaves this is again a refutation
of the claim that there uh was an
integer point
in this polytube all right so
stabbing planes reputations are really
simple they're just
decision tree referentials where you can
query layer inequalities
and the size of the proof is just the
number of queries in it
this was recently shown to be
polynomially related to the
bit complexity that's needed to write
down the proof
by deduction touring all right
um so
i said that staggering planes formalizes
branch and cut
but if you remember branching cut also
allowed for these cutting blends
deductions
um so we show that
these cutting plates deductions are
superfluous from the perspective of
proof complexity
because stabbing planes can just
simulate cutting planes
um and this is this is sort of
surprising because
stabbing planes is a tree-like group
system where you can't reuse things that
you've derived
whereas cutting planes is dag like you
can reuse
lines uh that you've derived okay
and in fact um we characterize cutting
planes proofs
as a subsystem of stepping planes
um which we call path like stabbing
planes
okay so a stabbing plane's query one of
these branches that we saw
is path-like if one half of the query
is the update polytope so this is
not a path like query uh because both
sides are not empty
but this one is the the left side is
empty right
um and yeah so path like stabbing planes
is one where
all the queries are path like we call it
path like because the proof looks like
one long path
um for every node at least one of its
children is the empty polytope
um and yeah so path like stabbing planes
is equal to cutting planes to show this
we just want to show that every cg cut
is a path like query uh so here's the cg
touch
uh x is great the b is the valid
hyperplane
and then we have uh taking the ceiling
of the right hand side there
um so now let's look at ax
less than or equal to the ceiling of b
minus one uh
clearly this lies outside of the
polytope uh and so if you intersect with
the polytope you get the empty polytope
and so the query ax is less than the
ceiling of b minus one
and ax greater or equal to the ceiling
of b is uh
a path like query and that shows that
you can stimulate cutting points and
style complaints
okay so um yeah
so this raises a natural question can we
separate the power
of cutting plants from stabbing plants
can we show that stabbing plants is
significantly more powerful
than cutting points so a natural
candidate
is the site formulas so these are the
canonical system
of uh mod two linear equations kind of
studied in improved complexity
on one hand we showed
that stabbing planes has
quasi-polynomial size proofs
of the site and formulas and on the
other hand
it was long conjectured that these
formulas were require exponential
complexity to refute in cutting planes
and uh this is pretty reasonable because
satan
is like the canonical hard example for
uh many of the algebraic proof systems
we study improve complexity
so really surprisingly um last year
deduction toy showed that there are
actually
quasi-polynomial-sized cut implants
proofs of sight
and they did this by showing that you
can translate
the stabbing plane's proof of satin into
cutting plants
all right so this raises a natural
question can
every stopping points proof be
translated into cutting points
so we give a partial answer to this
so we showed every stabbing plane star
proof so this is
stabbing planes proof where the
coefficients in the queries are
quasi-polynomially bounded
so have magnitude at most uh
n to the poly log n so every stabbing
plane star proof can be
quasi-polynomially translated into a
cutting plane's proof
okay and we do this in two steps
so before i showed that cutting blades
is equal to path like snapping planes
we actually show that it's equal to
something that seems to be
seems like it would be stronger than
path like static planes which we call
face like static planes
so recall the path like stab implants
you required that one side of the query
was empty
in phase like static planes you weaken
that you require that one side of the
query is a face of the polytope
so that is what let's suppose it's the
ax equal to b minus one side
so uh or ax lesser equal to the b minus
one side
um so it's so this is requiring that ax
is equal to b minus one
might not be empty but ax strictly less
than b minus one
is empty so on one half of the query
we um restrict to a face of the polytope
and
on the other half of the query it's just
arbitrary
um yeah and
so cutting planes is equal to this face
like statin planes
and then second we show that any
stabbing plane star proof
can be turned into a face like proof
with at most a quasi-polynomial blow up
in the size
and that completes the simulation
okay so this gives a nice corollary uh
which is that
if we allow for a quasi-polynomial
blow-up
which might be a lot we can kind of
think of
this stabbing playing star proof system
as a query version of cutting planes
right so just like how dpl
is the query version of tree like
resolution you just branch out variables
stabbing plant star is kind of a query
version of cutting planes when you
branch on
arbitrary integer limited qualities
all right and another corollary is that
we get
exponential lower bounds on uh the
length of stabbing plane star proofs
just by lifting the cutting planes lower
bounds to stabbing planes
and um another corollary
uh is that we get short refutations
quasi-polynomial size refutations of
any unsatisfiable system of linear
equations
over a finite field in cutting planes
um so yeah so i uh
if i have time um i can show you guys
this uh vj
vijay what do you think um
oh no maybe maybe uh we'll
take it offline is that okay okay okay
skip this
okay so i'll just end with some open
problems um
so on the right here i have um
like the hierarchy of the proof systems
that we've considered
so at the very top this rcp proof system
is the dag-like version of stabbing
planes
um it was introduced by crycheck
and this little red line here means that
there's a quasi-polynomial simulation
so cutting planes can quasi polynomially
simulate
snapping plane star okay so the first
open
question is whether we can reduce the
quasi-polynomial
in the simulation down to just
polynomial
um another one is can cutting planes
simulated stabbing planes um can we
get rid of this assumption on the size
of the coefficients
um also so the translation
of low coefficient stabbing planes bound
this stabbing plane star into cutting
planes
um naively causes a blow up in the size
of the coefficients
so can we get rid of that blob can we
show that boundary coefficient cutting
planes can simulate bounding coefficient
stabbing points
um then uh can
either stabbing planes or cutting planes
simulate the dag-like version of
stabbing planes known as rcp
so can't polynomially cutting planes
can't polynomially simulate it
um but it's possible that it could quasi
polynomially simulate it
um another question is whether
tree like cutting planes can refute
systems of linear equations
uh can can they refute like cyto uh or
are these formulas hard
for tree like cutting planes and finally
uh can we build
stabbing planes based solvers so
stabbing planes gives a nice
query like model just like dpl which
as everybody knows is the backbone of
of modern solvers uh so can we lift this
intuition into static points
all right uh yeah thanks
thank you noah for a fantastic talk
thank you uh
questions please i have a question
yeah moshe raised a son yes go ahead
please
so um you talk about dpd is kind of the
query language but dpl
dpl really usually will give it input
formula
have been reduced to 3cnf
so we have variable that really
corresponds to
to not just to basic variable but they
correspond to
two clauses by themselves
that doesn't doesn't really this implies
that dpl is kind of almost closest to
you to your stubbing calculus
so i'm um sure i completely understand
you take you take a a general formula
and the way you the way you reduce it to
to
to three cnn you create for every sub
formula
yeah a new variable that encodes a new
variable now when you clear that
variable you're
really querying a sub formula
and therefore this yeah this seems to me
to be actually quite
closer to your stubbing calculus
yes if you allow new variable
introductions like this it would seem to
be
kind of closer to like a uh yeah
a resolution over uh over clauses
which which would be simulated uh
at least by this yeah would be simulated
by staffing planes
in fact we there used to be a big
argument over the years between
this kind of cnf solver and so to speak
circuit solder people
said no we are losing this the structure
of the circuit let's let's
solve directly on the initial circuit
without doing the reduction to cnf
and that debate has died eventually i
think the reduction to cnf has won
and i think one reason it won't and i
don't know if anybody studied it
it has extra power because you branch on
sub formulas
yeah yeah that's true um
yeah it would seem to be significantly
more powerful if you're allowed to uh
branch on these
uh sub formulas
paul has a question paul go ahead oh
yeah
um sure it's actually yeah so it'd be
uh it's great talk uh can you just
briefly sketch the ideas i know you
didn't have time to
present them in full yeah yeah yeah so i
can
go back um
uh so basically the idea is uh
it's similar to the to the uh site and
upper bound if you know it
basically what you do is so you're gonna
refute these systems
of um linear equations of our finite
field
in um
in sort of a uh a divide and conquer way
so you're going to start with a
unsatisfiable system of linear equations
so i have one here on the left
uh this graph corresponds to the uh
each of the constraints you get like a
hyperedge and
you're just going to do a divide and
conquer procedure you're going to split
it in half
um and then you're going to recurse on
the side
uh uh well you're going to split it in
half you're going to
sum up that half of uh you're going to
sum up both of the constraints
um mod whatever finite field you're over
uh so i'll sum up the ones
in um in the first
half of the constraints mod the finite
field
some reason it stops sharing um
and this is going to give me a
constraint um
if i branch on
can can you try sharing again yeah i am
but it's
for some reason not letting me do it
okay okay then i guess maybe
yeah yeah yeah it's it's a it's a
standard kind of
divide and conquer algorithm basically
you you uh divide your set of
constraints into two halves
you uh sum them up mod the finite field
sum up each half mod the finite field
and then ask whether this sum uh mod the
final field
is even or i mean uh well it
in f2 it would be whether it's even or
odd um
over a larger field you'd ask what it's
uh
what its modulus is and then and then
you just recurse
um on the half that's unsatisfiable
under this setting
and you can simulate this in stabbing
plans by just branching
on the value of this sum
okay okay thank you um
i have a question but ian can you start
sharing your slides already
yep yeah nova i had a question regarding
um you recall that we had this
discussion about interference based
proof system so you add a clause
such that it doesn't preserve all
solutions but it preserves
at least one sambus has studied those in
the context of
sat similarly in this context you know
it would be interesting
when you add this one of these gw cuts
that you mentioned or
cg cuts sorry it would be interesting to
see
if you were to add cuts that preserve
solutions but not all solutions
there's at least one solution but not
all solutions
and uh the corresponding proof systems
that one could
you'll have to make an all this
interesting another solver that
makes sure that the clause that you add
or the
cg cut that you add has the right
properties but in the meanwhile paul
sorry i think sam has another question
sam please go ahead and
ask your question
okay so i'll read the question are there
candidates
for principles which are exponentially
hard for sp
yeah so the uh the obvious ones uh so so
all the lower bands for cutting planes
come from this
interpolation that's all reducing to
monotone circuit lower bounds
because now we have to simulate a
simulation of low weight stabbing planes
by cutting
planes this shows that these lower
bounds also hold for this low weight
stabbing plane so
i think the natural candidate formulas
for uh
that should be hard for stabbing plants
are uh just like anything you get
via interpolation so like clean coke
leak
or random cnf formulas or something like
this
yeah that would be my go-to thank you
noah thank you for a fantastic talk
thank you very much
yes